all right so one thing that i think is
underrepresented on trash taste is mecca
and
um so i bought a 400 mech transformer
well well we will go evacuate
too we got evangelion but uh we did we
we uh never got any like condoms gundam
or wait is this a building one i don't
think so i i really hope not is it a
building one
i'm [ __ ] buy a building open it up
okay
we're gonna we're gonna find out look
it's like perfectly flat of course
there's no way it would fit in that no
because i've seen i've seen this it's
like this being i've seen i've seen the
gun play and normally like if it's a
building one the back has you should
lose the backers
i just assume all gundam ones are just
the gun plus
if this yeah because because i i've
already wanted a gundam um that wasn't a
gunpla but it was impossible to find
yeah and uh yeah i have i haven't
actually seen gundam pathway yet but
alan will not shut up about it
alan is my editor and he's just like
gone and the biggest gundam simply no
allen's like gone if you do anything uh
just watch gundam hathaway because
actually no it is already no okay
wow look at that so alan i hope i've
made you proud by uh buying a gundam and
it's actually really nice apparently
gundam
isn't that a transformer according to
the bbc yeah
you should know right you were at the
bbc yeah
this is a this is there's so many parts
this is the best i can't i can't [ __ ]
build there's so many parts that might
as well be a gunfight look look this
this is this is like a pre-built gun
plot this is this is baby's first gun
player maybe the guys can build it off
camera very fast
yeah um so alan just told me to tell
people to watch gundam hathaway um
that's all i know i've heard very good
things i've actually like legit i've
heard so many good things about gundam
hathaway
um
so yeah we finally have a mecca apart
from you guys you've heard of the foot
but have you heard of the hand
that's it how many jojo figures did you
buy one more actually oh my god
i bought crazy diamond too okay
you know what i respect that i like what
i like i like i like crazy how many fake
figures did you buy [ __ ] off guard i
actually only bought two but there were
like two ones that built the [ __ ]
banks there were like two high quality
figures i go for high quality what are
you saying what are you insinuating
i go for quality it's all right connor
i'm here to help you with that jojo
collection
is this is this what is this thing this
is my most expensive figure i bought i
saw this figure pet shop and horus oh my
god uh would you how much did this cost
would you like to know yeah i know how
much it cost and joey vastly overpaid
for it i did vastly overpay for it but
that's all right because this is going
to be that's not the point that's not
that's not the point
the point can go on the [ __ ] at least
this can go on the shelf
i paid how much did you pay for it i
paid 990 for this
so i better [ __ ] win the most
expensive figure i swear to god i would
like to remind people this is uh valued
at 370 yeah how did it get how did you
pay 990 dollars for this i don't know
but this was the only way i was gonna
make do with my budget uh so yeah i got
it and you know what i ain't even mad
because i really like pet shop and horus
you're right you're right joey but uh
who who's the real winner here i think
it's mandarake yeah you know what i love
mondragon i go there often they made it
a little christmas present to you mom
300 profit you made a 300 profit off of
me i hope you're happy
um i let sydney choose a figure so of
course oh that's going to be a big
yeah so this was 275
am i allowed to like break this open
because i don't think we can show it
when buying hentai figures there are so
many hentai figures that come in boxes
that uh are just blank they don't
contain a picture at all so it's kind of
a gamble to see what kind of figure
you're gonna get um so i'm about to find
out now
okay
no that's that's her nips around that's
the arsenal argument yeah it's the
arsenal [ __ ] yeah so
sydney straight away you recognize the
asanagi figure
um i'm gonna keep this yeah keep it in
the plastic yeah
that's really nice though
trying to show the patrons
yes okay patreon okay okay i think i
think patrons deserve the quality that
is asanagi he's my favorite hentai
artist this is actually a pretty good
figure yeah
it's a really nice figure yeah oh wow
yeah
why is your teddy bear being bondaged i
don't know because it's arsenal you dude
what he's into some kinky [ __ ] what what
is this is this a replaceable ass
what is that it's goku black
can you choose the thickness that she's
going to be at you can
what the [ __ ]
dude this is next level hentai figures
man okay here's my uh here's my hold it
up hold it up for
i mean okay don't get me wrong it looks
amazing yeah it's not a thousand dollars
it's not a thousand dollars it's
probably very rare i've never seen it
before i've never seen it so i'm
guessing that's why it costs so much i
mean it's sick and it can go on the
shelf thank god yeah exactly it's not
too big it's not too big the basement
as well
what it can go on the shelf okay okay
okay some of
some of my all of mine can go in the
shelf we just need some
we just need some like black tape we can
do like a canonically censored um
canonically censored i realized this
part bigger snapped off
oh [ __ ] yeah what happened yeah oh no it
came it happened when i took it out of
the bag
it's all right we can we can bond it
that must be like super rare yeah that's
an easy fix uh
what else do you get what else you got
[ __ ] that nesco
don't tell me you got one as well gone i
just remembered i just bought some
other [ __ ] there's a naruto teddy bear
oh a kakashi teddy takashi teddy bear oh
he's my favorite fortnite character dude
yeah some some stuff i bought just to
pad out the number just to get as close
to uh yeah so question how much did you
guys do like
small scale adjustments to get to the
thing okay so the the difficult thing
about mandaraki
is that
some price tags had tax on it and some
price tags didn't right so trying to
calculate if the price you were getting
was actually like with tax or without
tax was like [ __ ] insane see because
i
just completely coincidentally i thought
i was gonna have to do that when i
bought my three figures yeah but then
when i calculated everything
i literally couldn't it was that it was
that close i really yeah i actually like
completely coincidentally i got insanely
close to three three three three i hope
as closer
than you two what's your cheapest figure
by the way gone
the pikachu because i've got an even
cheaper one have you actually 100 yen no
[ __ ] way well you just lost the point
there you've lost another point i lost a
point to gain a point
i thought for sure the pikachu would
have lost him a point i i was so
confident that i would get the exact
amount that i had no no he he he hasn't
what what was i bought for 100 yen so
no but what was that bought for what
challenge nothing
it was it was so that he could get as
close to all right uh um don't add a
point yeah it's it's whether he gets
close to the number enough do you like
out of mastercard
um you're almost sure sure
there you go you can have that one
this is going in the background corner
no it's not going anywhere
is that what you bought uh i bought one
more thing buy a figure from a show that
you'd all watched all right that was a
challenge right
nice ah okay well you know what i i like
i like it because you've bought you've
you've completed uh you've completed
this uh the code geass journey and
you've now found a mate for c2 which you
bought last year exactly right it's
perfect yeah so i can open this up let's
have a look i ain't even mad
is that everything you bought joey
that's everything i only bought three
things oh yeah because like the thing
about mandarin okay the [ __ ]
horoscope was a thousand dollars
i had to use my budget somehow that's
true that's true i think the biggest the
biggest difference between this figure
special on the last figure special is
that i was like i was like struggling to
find things to like fit the budget that
we had set yeah because
like we could have in most of the stores
we could have bought like the most
expensive figure there and a lot of
times we did buy the most expensive
figure there uh within reason yeah oh
that looks good that's a nice straight
up
clean fit
connect
[Music]
it's not a [ __ ] meme with that
oh nice i mean it's just dubs yeah i
mean that's just that's just the dub and
you've all seen code geos yeah
of course we love it love it yeah
is that all right i have one more thing
okay but connor i think me and you are
gonna need to swap uh because i i'm
gonna need i'm gonna need the table for
this uh conor can we swap for a second
why don't you put it there huh
also i want both your reactions at the
same time okay
okay
all right so i've got one more surprise
um it's a bit it's a bit uh out of the
box okay literally yeah you're telling
me i could see it
what the [ __ ]
sorry
um
that's the size of my girlfriend so i
was struggling to like fill up my budget
right and
mandarake had a lot of cool figures but
nothing that really like not nothing
that really likes you know spoke to me
yeah
um and then i was thinking
if you got another fate figure i'm gonna
[ __ ] kiss
don't uh don't guess what this is yeah
right so should we close our eyes i'm
gonna close my eyes
i swear to god gone if it's another fake
one
i'm so excited okay okay is this what it
feels like to be a small child during
christmas
you know what
i'm hearing a lot of uh struggling
oh
okay that was done
okay so before you open your eyes i just
want i just i just want to uh put a bit
of back story to this okay it better be
quick okay
so
um we like to [ __ ] on america a lot as
you know trash tastes part of trash
taste is [ __ ] on american culture
yeah okay
and so i thought instead of [ __ ] on
american culture for once why not
embrace it
okay
[ __ ] hell what was that what was that
that's like a [ __ ] steel brick and so
i thought we can embrace american
culture together for trash taste okay so
you boys can open your eyes
what the [ __ ] god
what the [ __ ]
okay um so this is an airsoft gun
um but
i did not know that airsoft guns look
like this
this is a steel brick do you want to
feel this what the [ __ ]
oh my god if if police come they're
going to arrest us that
are we going to get demolished oh my god
so for obvious reasons i'm not going to
put get out of the box yeah because this
looks way too realistic how much was
this
this was only 300 bucks
i like this is this is making me wonder
what the airsoft community is like in
japan
because this is
well if a zombie apocalypse happens i
know who i'm going to
like this is the closest thing
oh okay
of course uh this is not going out of
the box uh just in case anyone ever
thinks that this is anything but an
airsoft gun but uh youtube this is an
airsoft gun don't worry about it i think
we might have to blur for you we'll
probably have to blur for youtube
patrons
there you go enjoy uh
enjoy that and so yeah this is uh so
yeah i was like you know what
americans love gun so let's just
buy a gun
americans what do you think how
realistic this video is
could you have sounded more like a
neanderthal america love god america
love god but if you [ __ ] bought this
i can't believe god you didn't realize
the whole point of this
challenge what's
for the background of our set no i
wanted to buy [ __ ] to uh see your
reaction i thought that was the whole
point of the thing of the challenge
i wanted to get a good reaction out of
you guys oh you got a reaction where do
we put this
how do we get rid of this without
someone calling the police
we can figure that out later yeah let's
figure that out later